[Music]
over easter weekend a video went viral
which sparked perhaps a stronger
reaction than you might expect um that
is you might not have expected the
strong reaction if you've been
cryogenically frozen for the past half
century and were just thought out and
introduced to the internet 30 seconds
ago but anybody with a bit more
experience in cyberspace knows that
literally anything sparks a strong
reaction especially anything involving
politics religion or airplanes if you
combine the three you've got a real
powder keg on your hands not literally
we hope that brings us to uh this video
which shows a
a group of people on a flight standing
up and singing christian worship music
on the flight one of them is standing in
the aisle with an acoustic guitar
we know that that man with the guitar is
named jack jens jr he's a pastor and the
founder of kingdom realm ministries it's
called he and his crew were traveling
across europe and into ukraine
apparently over the past few weeks we
know all of this because the media has
published some not so favorable stories
about this incident and jen's has
actually been doxed on twitter by the
outrage mob
some prominent people have joined
backlash such as ilhan omar who tweeted
on saturday quote
i think my family and i should have a
prayer session next time i'm on a plane
how do you think it will end
yeah some people uh played music on a
plane
ilhan wasn't even there
and yet she has found a way to make
herself the victim of it
ilhan is good at playing this game it's
like six degrees of kevin bacon except
except
instead of connecting an actor kevin
bacon she's able to connect any event in
the world to her own personal victimhood
narrative
it's almost impressive but before we
address ilhan's claims in any more
detail let's first watch
the controversial video in question
[Music]
now let me just say up front that um i
can very much relate to the bald guy in
the foreground staring helplessly into
the camera you could see him right there
uh
some of the passengers seem to be
relatively pleased with the performance
but i think i'd be reacting more
like that guy right there
this would be in many ways like this
situation for me would be my personal
hell i appreciate the message of the
song
but i really personally
from an aesthetic standpoint cannot
stand acoustic youth pastor christian
music
the idea of being trapped in a metal
tube 30 000 feet in the air with a guy
strumming his guitar two feet from my
eardrums is traumatizing to think about
if i was in an exit row i might consider
making a break for it this is almost as
bad as somebody eating an onion bagel in
the seat right next to you an experience
that i've suffered throughout more than
one occasion
in those cases with respect to the bagel
chompers i think it'd be it'd be legally
and morally justifiable for the air
marshal to just escort the offender off
of the plane in the middle of the flight
i would not advocate for the same
penalty for the worship team in the
video because at least their hearts are
in the right place
but i do think
that you should just give people a
choice before subjecting them to
contemporary christian folk music
consent is key i mean i'm christian and
i don't even like it you can't just
assume that everybody wants to hear that
i mean what if somebody stood up in the
aisle and started yodeling
what if a polka band played accordion
music all the way over the atlantic
what if god forbid beyonce was on the
flight and started singing a cappella i
mean where does it end my problem is
with the singing then not with the
message
but for ilhan omar and the others in the
online outrage
brigade it's the opposite
that's why none of these people
complained when the cast of the lion
king sang the circle of life on a plane
in australia let's watch that again
[Applause]
i think i am
[Music]
[Applause]
my god it's an epidemic
imagine being in a stuck being stuck in
a plane with that that's again my
my nightmare i'm already on a plane and
then the plane turns into high school
musical that's i cannot i would rather i
just i'd want to be dead
and yet if i bring my kids on a plane
and they make a noise louder than a
whisper everyone in the surrounding rows
will turn around and give us icy glares
of death like god forbid your kid make
any sound at all
and yet these people could turn the
whole flight into a broadway performance
that strikes me as a double standard
meanwhile ilhan omar is looking for a
different double standard she says that
she and her family you know if they
prayed on a plane people would get upset
well first of all given that omar
married her brother
prayer is certainly not the most
upsetting thing that omar does with her
family second
i don't need to speculate about what
would happen if muslims prayed on a
plane i was just recently on an 18-hour
qatar airways flight to and from africa
muslim prayer is so common on those
flights that they actually put the
coordinates to mecca up on the seat back
screens to help facilitate it
on many flights around the muslim world
they'll actually play an islamic prayer
over the the intercom before takeoff
muslims are not shy about expressing
their faith loudly and publicly
many mosques including in the united
states will play the islamic call to
prayer over loudspeakers throughout the
day so that the whole town can hear it
and what if any white person were to
complain about any of that
what if i had whined about the muslim
prayer on my guitar flight
what what if someone who lived near a
mosque said that they didn't want to
hear the muslim call to prayer
how would ilhan omar respond to that
well we all know she'd rush to the scene
and start vomiting words like bigotry
and islamophobia all over the place
she's searching for a double standard
but all she needs to do is look in the
mirror she's the one with the double
standard as usual
now you might point out that the muslim
prayer on flights
generally happens in and around heavily
muslim areas of the world fair enough
but the west is heavily christian not as
much as it used to be not as much as it
should be but still predominantly
christian according to any survey i've
ever seen on the subject so it's the
same old story here ilhan omar
does not believe that anything in the
west should reflect the west's dominant
historical culture and religion
the middle east is allowed to wear its
muslim culture with pride but the west
cannot do the same with its historical
christian culture according to omar
ilhan omar
was born in somalia which is one of the
worst places on earth it is an absolute
hellhole it's a wasteland a failed state
her family fled that place sought refuge
here and they were welcomed with open
arms
and yet she despises her adopted home
the christian west took her in elected
her to congress made her one of the most
influential people in the country and
still she has no gratitude
she has no love for the place that saved
her life or for the place
or for the people who inhabit that place
she came into this culture our culture
and immediately decided that the culture
must change
not just change but be entirely
dismantled and rebuilt to reflect her
own ideology and priorities and if you
think that the last statement there is
reading a little bit too much into her
complaining about people singing
christian songs on a flight you'd be
right but i'm not reading that into her
reaction to the flight video i'm
actually just quoting her directly let's
listen to that
as long as our economy
and political systems prioritize private
without considering who is profiting
who is being shut out
we will perpetuate this inequality
so we cannot stop at criminal justice
system
we must begin the work of dismantling
the whole system of oppression wherever
we find it
dismantle the whole system
gets here from somali and wants to
dismantle it all
and you know she's coming from a country
that was entirely dismantled where all
the systems are dismantled
so you think she
would have had her fill of that by now
so the reason why her complaints about
the christians on the flight rub some of
us the wrong way is that it's consistent
with a long-established theme
and that theme is omar's lack of
gratitude
and that in fact is a much broader theme
that encompasses more than just ilhan
omar we don't inculcate or encourage
gratitude in any of the people who we
accept into our country
or any of the people born here naturally
that's the underlying issue
goes a lot deeper than what she said
about people singing on a plane and it's
for this deeper underlying reason that
ilhan omar is today probably not for the
first time and certainly not for the
last cancelled
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated